la nouveauté alors c'est simple je suis
descendu dans la rue en faisant passer
pour un journaliste un le tout
légèrement déguisée au cas où nous
reconnaissent même si c'est pas rêver
depuis trois ans et je leur dis que j'ai
loupé une manif voilà que j'étais
journaliste je loupé la manif et je leur
demande de me rendre ses relances les
gens sont très très sympa en faisant
jarry c'était dans cette manif s'ils
peuvent se débrouiller répondre à deux
questions et vous allez voir certains
sont meilleurs menteurs que d'autres on
a appelé ça eu un gros brainstorm le
mytho trottoirs qu'on avait la manif des
agriculteurs en la loupe et on va se
faire défoncer
si on ne fait pas ça va être une galère
ça t'embête pas de question juste ça va
c'est passé il y avait du monde tout ça
et basta quoi hockey et dans les rues de
paris aujourd'hui pour cette grande
manifestation des agriculteurs avec
ludovic un qui faisait partie de ce
cortège
ludovic est ce que vos revendications
ont été obtenues eh ben on l'espère en
tout cas on était bien nombreux cette
fois ci on espère obtenir gain de cause
alors vous avez vous même une
exploitation sait dans quel domaine moi
je fais de la pomme de terre
on sait que les exploitations viticoles
sont à 0 3% de baisse
quelles seraient les mesures du côté
viticole que vous prendriez vous écoutez
moi je ne suis pas je sais pas ce qui se
passe dans le viticole moi je vous dis
c'est la terre la patate c'est vraiment
de questions je veux juste y a eu des
mots ça s'est bien passé
on voulait juste genre le plus parce
qu'ils étaient tous en blouse dans la
manif un ça vous prend de seconde dans
les rues de paris pour cette grande
manifestation des chirurgiens avec
jérémy justement chirurgien orthopédiste
qui est avec nous pour jérémy alors est
ce que cette manifestation s'est bien
passé l'idée sur une grande mobilisation
oui beaucoup de monde la police dit 500
parle plus de 1500 on doit entre les
deux je pense alors que pensez-vous du
conflit qui oppose aujourd'hui les
chirurgiens au centre hospitalier public
qui les oblige à reverser 3 % de leurs
honoraires
c'est un petit peu abusé tout jaloux
donc vous vous êtes plutôt pour verser
ses honoraires non merci beaucoup à
jérémie ça il y avait un grand une
grande convention de bd avec que des
fans de bandes dessinées à torse nu et
voilà on est arrivé une heure trop tard
si tu peux nous arranger 2
je suis fait un des gars de bd ou alors
on a un petit recul mais ça fait genre
tu sortais du truc chiant du truc de
mener ce genre tu sors du truc de bd je
te pose vraiment de questure bateau
c'était bien bonjour à tous aujourd'hui
dans les rues de paris pour couvrir
cette grande manifestation des fans de
comics et c'est clément qui sort tout
juste de la convention et qui est le fun
le double de temps torse et sa ruse
alors que l'univers du tort je pourrais
était de faire le christ heures avant de
recruter un pour tous tous pour un merci
clément